I sort of went back and forth about whether
to even do this story because there is so
much resistance
since now to any Russia related news.
Either you already understand what happened
or you've totally bought into the witch hunt
conspiracy theory type stuff.
So I really was unsure about whether to even
talk about this.
But in the end, this is actually really big
news and I decided it was an important story
to do.
The Senate intelligence committee, which is
controlled by Republicans in a new report
has found that the Kremlin directed Russia's
social media meddling in the 2016 election
period and this is, it's becoming, or it should
be a post partisan issue.
The Republican led Senate intelligence committee
has a long list of recommendations for Congress
and for Donald Trump and for social media
companies to prevent the same thing from happening
in 2020 but we've already seen Senate majority
leader Moscow, Mitch McConnell block every
single effort to prevent 2020 meddling.
So it's going to be an uphill battle.
The report suggests that social media companies
add transparency to the sources of political
advertisements on their platforms, that they
notify users about exposure to misinformation
and hilariously, hilariously, in a depressing
sense, the panel report recommends that the
Trump administration remind voters about the
dangers of foreign interference in 2020 I
laughed out loud when I read that.
How quaint, right?
The Trump administration should really warn
people that warn people that they benefit
from it.
They have no interest in stopping it.
Why on earth would they warn people?
This is the whole problem that we're dealing
with in many of the techniques and the players
that are mentioned in the report were already
known to us.
They talk about the IRA, the internet research
agency.
They were a big player.
They talk about one strategy that we knew
about which was to target black Americans,
particularly in parts of the country like
Baltimore and Ferguson, Missouri, which were
experiencing racial unrest and priests specifically
target those areas, black voters in those
areas to foment more racial unrest.
The real news here is not any of that.
We knew all of that stuff.
The news is that we've learned that the Kremlin
itself was directing it and that conclusion
was reached not by, you know, whoever Trump
claims it was reached by.
It was reached by a bipartisan panel that
is led and controlled by Republicans, not
a partisan democratic hack job or whatever.
Trump will obviously claim.
Now let's do the normal disclaimers here because
I think that this is where maybe some on the
left start to, uh, I dunno about push back,
but they start to question this entire story,
which is extraordinarily well backed by evidence.
Russia does not only metal in our elections,
right?
So when we talk about Russian meddling in
our elections, I'm not asserting nor implying,
nor have I heard anyone assert or imply that
Russia only metals in American elections,
they metal in others too.
And in fact, that's what makes us so sure
that it's happening, that it is not atypical
for Russia to be meddling in others elections.
The difference is other countries seem more
committed in stopping them.
Other countries seem more interested in preventing
it from happening.
Now let's go to the next disclaimer.
Or it's not even really a disclaimer, it's
just context.
The United States also has a long history
of meddling in other elections and you will
sometimes hear people on the left, sometimes
the Leninist left say, who are we to say anything?
We've been meddling in elections for a really
long time.
Yeah, okay.
So countries try to meddle in the elections
of other countries for their own benefit.
That doesn't change anything about wanting
to stop Russia from doing it right and wanting
to stop Russia from doing it.
Specifically for the benefit of Donald Trump.
I was, uh, reminded when reading about this
of the words of a great modern philosopher,
Donald J. Trump, who once said, he said it
quite recently.
In fact, you know what we used to do in the
old days when we were smart with treason,
we used to handle it a little bit differently
than we do now.
Very interesting words on such an occasion.
If you were Vladimir Putin on the day after
the November of 2016 election, how do you
prevent death from uncontrollable laughter
when you see that?
It worked.
When you see that you succeeded.
I listened.
I don't know every instance of Russian meddling
in foreign elections over the last hundred
years.
So I can't say with certitude, but has there
been any greater accomplishment by Russian
meddling in foreign elections than the election
of Donald Trump?
I'm asking the question.
If somebody has an example that is more egregious
or notable or whatever, uh, I want to hear
it from you.
And I hope that at a certain point, because
I know that listen, just every story I do
is a balance.
There's a risk and a reward to every story
that I choose or just stories that I choose
to exclude from the show.
I know enough to know that there is a nonzero
part of my audience, my core audience, even
that believes the witch hunt.
Never nothing, nothing there.
We're actually the bad guys meddling elsewhere
in Russia didn't do anything to us conspiracy
theory cause that's actually the real conspiracy
theory.
I know that there are people in my audience
who have fallen for that.
Um, try to separate your reflexive reaction
that has been built up over the last two and
a half years, often on very bad reporting.
Uh, and just understand that this is a bipartisan
Republican led report that has found this.
If you want to argue that they had bad data
and thus their conclusions are wrong, make
that argument but make it with data.
Don't just call it a witch hunt.
Don't fall for the Republican talking points
because one of the ways you don't even people
may not even understand this and this is a
real problem.
One of the ways that the right wins is when
they convinced the left to adopt their talking
points.
When we start making the same stupid arguments
that they make using the same language, particularly
when they're wrong, of course we lose hard
because we completely lose any ability to
see common sense and reason and rationality.
So that's my request.
Don't fall for that.
This weekend we are having a membership blow
out.
We are, it's been like a year or longer since
we've done this.
Membership is available year round and it's
our number one funding source.
This weekend we are going to have a one day
membership blowout.
Our biggest uh, fun a membership drive of
the year.
The only one we've done this year actually,
which by definition makes it the biggest.
We are going to do a single day massive discount
off of memberships.
You can sign up at a major discount if you
so choose.
All you have to do is get on our newsletter,
our newsletter subscribers will get an email
this weekend.
The subject will be something like that email
you've been waiting for or that discount code
I've been telling you about and it will give
you the instructions to take advantage of
this big ugly.
I mean this is just huge, huge membership
discount.
So get on our newsletter@davidpakman.com while
you're doing stuff, follow me on Twitter at
D Pacman.
Follow the show on Twitter at David Pakman
show and a lot of people asking me on Twitter
over the last day or two, will I be streaming
next week's democratic debate.
And I don't know if people are asking me that
because of my recent app appendectomy and
I've not been streaming or because of the
copyright issues we've had with debates on
CNN before.
My goal is to be streaming the debate next
week and I will have more information about
where that will be happening.
Um, early next week.
Quick break,
big Friday show
for
you toda